the livestream no one's here but people
who watch afterwards were here that's so
high I'm just gonna get the the link the
lincolni link as per usual
by the way that me screaming was just me
trying to get hyped this is stream I was
like awake oh also it's a freaking close
game look how pretty it is
I'm so excited especially just the fact
that they're using the gorilla gorilla
gorilla engine which is the same engine
that a Okajima is using although he has
modified it a ton to make death
stranding and we've all seen those
trailers if we haven't why not go and
watch those trailers they are freaking
amazing like that man is a legend and
his game looks so good I mean yeah it
looks so good but yet they using the
same game engine so I've always wanted
to play this and I mean not just because
of that but also because I mean it's got
like a cool sassy female protagonist
with awesome hair may I add my hair is
very fluffy today but I mean she is hair
goals
I'm clicking in the microphone that's
probably really annoying sorry and not
only that freaking robots animals like
huh yeah it just seems neat anyway I'm
gonna tweet out the where at the bloody
hell is for link
what see we swear I'm just gonna view it
on my page dear Dez
shush computer don't make noises publish
what keep anything publish and boop
tweet there you go let me pop up the
chat so I can see you guys hey hey hey
[Music]
sweet and I'll just keep this up just in
case the stream goes bad stream should
be good today though guys you wanna know
why because all my friends have been out
drinking and I was invited but I was
like hell no tonight is the night that I
sit in and play horizon zero dawn with
my subscribers me were like okay you
have no life yes ha but yeah because
they're not in I'm think I think I'm the
only one using the Internet
yeah I think so so you should be good it
should be good into that today which is
a good thing sweet but I'll keep this up
anyway so just in case it starts to get
red and it's like bad stream status and
then I'll get all upset anyway I haven't
even been listening to is it making
noises
a little but a little uh I'm watching
video about the new last of us my life
oh my gosh yes that video that video I
mean the game looks very good I'd say
they don't have a life that's nice
thanks Ryan
I thought you meet yeah like everyone
you don't have to go out although it
should be more sociable but money too
right who's got my money for all that so
yeah without further ado
shall we play let's play my light is
gonna get in the way of my gameplay
that's gonna be so annoying let's play
on normal mode
if you want me to change anything to do
with it audio let me know but I think it
should be okay
[Music]
oh that's a lot of berries
you're quite the gatherer under the bust
now go and see if you can find someone
[Music]
where's her mom
or person who tells her she's doesn't
good at making Verisign she said I got
married come with me
why is she being so rude she's an
outcast to be shunned me she's only a
child come on
[Music]
she squishes those berries
so she not have my parents so family
from down here frost frost
who is Ross he won't hear me
kind of cave
look at that big ass right here hey
Michael hey George hey Alex hey Jonathan
hey man hey Hewitt I'm here with Nicole
hey Justin hey Oscar
hey big me yeah hey mentor's hey it's
big bees first dream and they like it
thank you welcome to stream glad you
already live here oh my god she's Batman
looks tight then I can get through okay
how do I this must be a ruin of the
metal world what are the old places I'm
very I'm very like intrigued in how they
did the hair in this game just because I
have tried to make hair before my own 3d
models and it's not easy not at all and
I'm pretty impressed anyway what am I
trying to do
hey rats what's that
wait what does that door remind me of
fall out it's like we're in a vault
okay we're going into the cave never
going
what is running out to find a way out
yeah
my love my friends get off should have
physics or something else doesn't love a
button
wait so just came in that way just
interesting
I'm gonna understand what all these
mechanisms are so I know this is like
obviously sad very futuristic world
Jesus Christ it's not even 9 o'clock
where no is I know oh my gosh I got some
really exciting news to tell you but I
can't I don't know if I'm gonna stay so
I just told you that some things that I
can't tell you hopefully I can tell you
soon I basically got invited somewhere
but it clashes with my dissertation so
need to see whether I can actually go
but I'm going cuz like I can't say no to
this opportunity
but I'll tell you soon maybe next week
I'll tell you or follow me on Twitter
and I'll tweet out snapchat what that's
it's weird oh it's so nice yeah it's not
a bad place to die
the hell is that
nice
it's a I get phooey
I just do this
[Music]
uh-huh
I'll buy a few to put the deaf person
that's so cool
so can we like interact with these
[Applause]
looking at the bunker door oh no don't
tell me there's something behind my hat
don't really think what is bad though
not good okay let's just go up here
another door maybe this device I found
can help heavy cell in something mundane
there's something in the room Oh what's
this and to face unavailable sit through
the wall
[Applause]
hello rat it was a small rat here is
turn hallo luck counterclockwise
Melissa do
how do I know which way I'm supposed to
do
and there's something though ah well go
up go up
thank you for 5 pounds a breeze I can't
ever remember what I did like it made
something up and then I can't remember
what it was
do you guys I know hand dance I can
donate Oh wasn't my robot heart today I
always think I can do it I'm like out
drinking anyway thank you what did you
say
did you see Jays reviews livestreamer
and is just an hour ago okay I saw it
too he was playing the game on the
hardest difficulty no no I didn't I
don't actually watch anyone else live
stream funny enough I actually well I
watched a couple twitch streamers but I
don't really watch anyone on the
youtubes on the youtubes hey Austin
Grubbs and else Nord and Max today and
leather bath and yet so many people hi
anyway while my doing I'm leaving
where's the door
store chains colors - okay
so I'll just do the same thing again I
can open it now so I'm going so luring
the little little steps
another dead person hit this way it's
the best I can do birthday Isaac daddy
sure does love his little big man
where's my cake daddy can't be there
with you and mom but he's cuddly sure
does love his little big man look daddy
can't be there with you and mom but we
can still have a party right
sure we can
[Music]
daddy sure does love
that's so sweet and so sad at the same
time that's a very cool I hope we get to
see that throughout the whole game just
like random people's highlighters little
things where you find your tape
recorders whatever from people who are
there so you understand history of the
game a bit more we zoo your tiny
am I missing things should I have been
looking around should I be exploring
like what is in here what is this
well Happy New Year dear diary can you
believe we actually celebrated last
night well we did kind of director Evans
invited everyone to gather in the
community room Oh that'd be my where she
got the party hats that was a ghoulish
touch so then we said watching the clock
tick down to midnight and I'm thinking
forget the symbolism of this ham I've
been worth it if Skyler gotten drunk
again but yeah there's none of them
I saw them lining up but cattle and it's
the letter house but this is my like at
each other
Shana handing out meds like being alive
is some kind of pain to be eased off and
what a period at the end of my life
sentence no net ellipses hell an
exclamation mark so if that upsets
whoever finds this too bad
oh one exclamation mark to anyone
anymore
did you hear yourself why she's so cute
she's like I still do that surprising I
can't afford it fighting stairs is my
house
yeah asking the same question again
triangle okay
exclamation marks quad what up yeah come
on man let's keep listening people's
thoughts
Machu Picchu always wanted to see that
Machu Picchu I wouldn't say no to much
of Picchu
[Music]
so I can't listen to the Moors two
minutes
[Music]
beautiful my face baby
as for us
she doesn't you don't belong down there
come
yeah but I got some cool new tank rust
in such places are forbidden alloy I
fell in they are of the metal world what
is that on your face nothing did you
find it down there
[Music]
give it to me hallo such things are
dangerous
No
well you're gonna go sneaking away from
home you need to know how to survive in
the wild
call me like home now starting tomorrow
learn to hunt
so she's an outcast so I'm guessing
there's like pockets and civilizations
and people who live kind of more like
savages on the outside of that
[Music]
what is she doing
and meditation
take your bow
so she's gonna be a hybrid between like
enough muttering to that plaything uh we
descend to the valley now follow old and
new basically hi honk rattle
the wilds can be dangerous a loin you
will need to stay close and do as I say
I know now you're still scratched up
from that fault you took yesterday
issues matter take this medicine pouch
wow she's fine
see this plant over here
it's called South brush come gather its
berries in your pouch the woman didn't
like my berries out eat the berries yeah
men they may taste bitter but they can
save your life
always keep your pouch full of medicinal
berries flowers buds okay where are we
this family is just a part of all
mothers in price the Norwich right
watches these lands and keeps out the
most dangerous machines usually
by the man
further downriver we'll find a herd of
machines and I will teach you how to hot
are they dangerous
all machines are dangerous Abele their
power must be respected
I will be beside you
my shoes coming Crouch follow me
that's not matter crashing okay that's
cool I wouldn't know how these two met
there now stay low you don't know any
way such machines are called Watchers
you must learn to avoid their gaze if
you weren't to survive and wines I will
show you this impulse and do as I do
stay still wait for it to pass
now kilo and follow me across the trail
to that tall grass is it gonna come back
[Music]
at a pass
so we just hiding we're not gonna kill
them I want the whip at the butt
oh here it is
I don't love her that reminiscent of
dinosaur the crops walking is quieter
than upright
waetford
Helen Spears football and now I don't
think the are photo into her because she
calls him rust and she keeps like
reminiscing or just thinking about
family and getting all upset she doesn't
have one other thing yeah she doesn't
call him doubt he did well they didn't
see or hear you
noise why is that eyes now stay close
that herd should be just ahead okay
[Music]
Wow who's that
that's called park our Paul but once you
up there smiling at us
team well ignore him
we're outcasts and he is of the tribe
maybe he does our civilization is come
now watch we outcasts what did we do so
many questions
thank you
[Music]
oh yeah these are called Striders
get why'd you chase them off to show you
how some machines startled easily if
they detect you run away their best
approach by stealth don't worry we'll
catch up with them further down the
valley you'll see so much stuff I'm
wrong now I want you to find some rocks
that fit the cup of your hand
why do as I say a lawyer and gather the
rocks I'm going I'll show you how to use
them we're gonna use them follow to lead
the creatures other places right one of
the things
even fastest night you can't know
there's the hurt all right it's time to
throw some rocks
hi James oh right no but they can
distract them draw them into traps like
that watch her over there it must be
dealt with or warn the herd and send
them running before we get in range how
the machines speak to each other a boy
unless they are first silenced usually
not trying to harass them right there
just let me out to the room crying Jules
well that kind of makes me feel bad wait
for my signal
wait for his signal now you okay now
what I wanna can't water come girl it's
safe now it's about Harvester kill so I
can teach you how to make arrows
can't see my freaking head on the way
gather stalks of redwood from the plants
over there
which would use the stocks as arrow
shafts and metal shards for our heads
okay how do I do that
there's a rock
Oh Alma our okay
good you'll never make lies yeah how to
craft what you need let's put those
arrows to use follow
I've got all that Flair I saw quite a
funny post the other day saying um video
game video game designers whatever stop
putting so much lens flare in game is my
eyes aren't camera lens right okay but
this is my first present so it makes
more sense
strike one of the weaker machines but
even a weak machine can kill a hunter if
she's careless its height is the dick
but there are spots word is abundance I
guess another
[Music]
up there
what
hey hey lawyer the herd saw you I have
to try again I was like you trip my
kills
okay so I can tag the target
so how do i stir on it to that is that a
weakness [ __ ]
how did you guess that the device it
shows me that plaything stop playing
games
hey dude take down that Strider target
the eye or the canister if it charges
started lessons here but you say okay
yeah you did well today and you have
much to learn
yeah we train again what was that that
boy the one running the brave trails
follow a light quick hey where'd he go
well that current did not faze her
[ __ ]
then they seem it's only a matter of
time before the machines find that boy
and kick him to death oh so they did
count what if I shoot it'll cause a
stampede
then I can see the path they take stop
telling stories
I can speak through she will not
doing it and you should await a weapon
okay
stealth mode you know how good I am at
stealth games let's do this so I'm sure
this'll be a piece of bass though she's
got this she's got a little device gonna
take a while okay bakit let's go
she's teeny yeah stuff
no we're not gonna where you go here and
then where your back your back that way
okay let's go
I feel like an exposed okay hey like
what is that breathing okay hey Drake
shush your face I don't know why you say
languages I come with me
I have never any other language as well
anyway
I don't want to hear yet
okay do you stop when you get that bunny
making me feel a little tense okay go go
go
hello
[Applause]
tip get down oh my god
shish
this way how are you doing this
shut up the tap
stay here watch it
oh [ __ ] it this way shut up okay this
way
rs10 told you I could do a rough hello
Ivan and Jim
so there's no plaything
it's not just an earring wait Oh mother
bless that girl bless you both can you
get your tribe to stop big [ __ ] to
us now I just wanted I feel your lips
they are outcasts both and she nope
apparently not
she's motherless come now it's not my
fault
dr. mother's heart wait what
it's mother like their God or something
that boy should not have spoken to us
it's against tribal law
we'll go home now don't again what are
we gonna try by that I know the way
stay away no mother
yes so now I have some ways as though
she's gonna crush it into like ash okay
aim for his head Oh flash points are for
moments of emotional choice all this is
cool
how alloy expresses her presidency is up
to you far I didn't read all not the
rock from his hands yeah that one
definitely the brain always the brain
although usually my heart takes over but
the brain is the best option
hey I have a new follower
[Music]
you're bleeding look whilst where were
you can indeed hold still
I'll get it why am I in Out Boy this is
not the time I want to know boy I've
told you before that's not for us to
know you were just a newborn when the
matriarchs brought you to me so the
matrix they know yeah it's not so simple
but they brought hey Lloyd we are
outcasts so how do I make them tell me
the matrix there is a way perhaps so
tell me it will be dangerous how it will
take years of training
I don't care how do I do it tell me the
proving the tribe's rite of passage held
every year those who pass become Braves
but to the one who wins the matriarchs
granted boon yes whatever the winner was
you know do it
whatever it takes
[Music]
I'll win the proving she could do it the
inspirational music is rising the
training will be hard I am ready for the
montage follow fun full of energy hey
it's winter this is the montage
spring
Oh summer
do-do-do-do-do-do-do awesome
dirty dirty dirty
Thank You rust
[Music]
oh my god
I want to do an epic month how much ever
you like
shebang
focus essence for an intro
[Music]
hey there she is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
does she wink or blink
I couldn't tell that was pickle
amagai you transform into hot dog roast
I'm glad that so many people are saying
this okay we're like you're gonna let
this last
I didn't want to play by this when I
what if he came out I just never did who
days before the proving and he goes off
without me he wouldn't do that
oh it's two days before the proving okay
spear knock off machine armor using I
won't write anything in here I was a
save point okay
that's handy no I haven't played frozen
welds River for sure
and he said we go hunting this morning
why isn't he here where's he gone to
we'll find out I'm sure he hasn't gone
without meaning to you
I mean without good reason to
what's he doing up there he's just Oh
standing there what's going on with him
Haley you're here
something good to know I good thing I
know how to track now I'm gonna go with
my heart this time you want to be alone
no we must speak but I've been thinking
about your training a lie you've learned
to hunt in order to survive but I fear
there's a lesson I failed to teach you
would you learn it now of course I'll
always learn what you have to teach
there has been some trouble recently it
affords an opportunity to learn this
lesson but it will be dangerous he was
come prepared or you will die
descend into the embrace and hunt until
you've gathered the parts for fire
arrows fire arrows what kind of trouble
are we talking about once you have the
parts you will meet me there at the gate
beyond the village of mothers heart the
north gate at the edge of the embrace
yes now be on your way
is something else bothering you no I'm
fine
hmm anything else you want me to do
while I'm down in the embrace odd grotto
might be out of food by now you could
hunt a week's worth of meat for if you
find the time wouldn't mind if she'd say
thanks just once grata follows the law
their science towards us is honorable
if you say so oh so she's from on one of
the tribes are you worrying about what
happens after the proving what happens
is clear you'll be accepted as one of
the triangle I will still be about - Oh
until the end with the toads they really
were last even if the tribe accepts me I
won't there is much to do anyway we'll
discuss this later okay I bet it's gonna
be something some people like I never
taught you hard to love I'll go gather
the parts but I'm also gonna pay course
to visit a LOI that man breaks the law
every time he speaks to you and I'm glad
he does I want to buy a trip caster and
no other trader will sell to outcasts
stock it with ammunition then you'll
find use for that weapon tonight
yes try hollowing her whenever you see
this all right the azimuth the north
gate yeah she is like Meredith's embrace
me um how do I do I like him what does
that mean
[Music]
inventing crafty
[Music]
special items nor look outfit Norma
Jeane
and something about her hair
[Music]
oh you meant me try a hairstyle oh
bloody hell I'd love to you I mean I do
Platt my hair when I get stressed I put
like a little Platts in it this was the
job I just jumped no I'd love see I mean
my hair is kind of like that anyway
doesn't look like it on this camera but
it is quite orange in the sunlight and
then it goes a bit brighter on the
bottom I think yeah big claps in it try
how the bloody hell would you do that
top bit though that looks hard I can't
do have my hair's just like a mess all
the time
but that looks so cool maybe I'll go to
hairdressers yeah I'll get them stiff
meets like I'm how do I get down there
all right I'm gonna go oh this looks fun
how do I do this to him he's wrong
I just opened them up
[Music]
where is a this guy that I need to visit
that's mother's heart is this him past
yeah so I'm guessing I don't want to go
to mother's heart because they're all
gonna banish me cuz they're so mean why
do you still want me to open this up
luhan's is that why he came from
[Music]
why do you still miss the embrace my
whole life I've never gone beyond this
valley that'll change after the proving
two days two days until I get answers
two days and I'll know who she was
is that them over that I always cast out
at birth as if there could be an excuse
for that all right time to gather the
parts for some fire arrows I should find
a herd
thank you saw announce spam Oh highly
cast thanks for coming even though you
can only come from moment by appreciate
it
mother's heart few more days then I'll
know what it's like in there people
living in one place I guess no one ever
gets lonely in there
[Applause]
hey bunny
[ __ ]
Oh
all right again
should go there
I'm not being very stealthy shite
no I'm in the I'm in the bushes I don't
really know I'm coming out now alone
okay
done gone shoes meeting
they weren't looking for me
you gotta go
thank you very much
rebel Raptor is exactly Jonathan and
hello India love Alan Obama I'm sorry
all Fox I've ever had I love foxes
sweet quick seed
ah look at all these little particles
[Music]
there's a very pretty game I wonder how
they got that depth of field and my
camera as well cuz they you see the the
particles near the camera are very
opaque and the when spot oh wait are
they or is it just now and a cycle of
random opaqueness it's on a cycle okay
that's not as impressive well where'd
you go
mother's cradle huh interesting
but one second I need to pop to the loop
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
or you to pull up actually it's kinda go
grab a beer but I'll receive it to later
sleeping for the weekend
hello yeah ground how was the game
development going good actually I got my
feedback back from my pre-production on
the game and I got my feedback from the
coding lecturer and he said yeah he said
like he sees potential and he likes that
I'm trying to use like SDKs and stuff
cuz apparently like the other students
haven't because most of my into the arts
to be fair oh my god so [ __ ] talking to
you it's your fault okay go back okay uh
yeah city's really good basically yeah
I'm on track just stay for like a 2-1 at
the moment that he said he understands
the pre-production when he used STK in
service and blah blah blah it takes up a
lot of time oh it's very weird actually
there was one bit of feedback that was
really strange that was from my head of
year and she said I'm using like old-age
English she was like you need to use
more modern English because i used the
word observant in the game design
document so i lost marks for that but
then my other lecturer who gave me their
feedback was like don't really know what
that's about
because like a it's not really that old
and be it shouldn't really
that much but apart from that yeah it's
all good it's all good huh stop blabbing
now this is cool
what am i doing no well like where am I
going can I get up here Wow so this is
this what I'm supposed to be gathering
everything hey you can't spit in my
balls
other than they can see me from here
die die die die I shoot you in the eye
Jesus
okay
holiday concert
what was it again never mind one sec
yeah this will help I shot oh okay so
the whole freakin hard run off because
I'm an idiot but how do I make more bows
again was it fun oh no that's helped did
you do that one uh-huh
Kratz sweet ballz
what the hell you have a son for - to
you oh you are one angry donkey I know
doesn't get it in any of its thoughts
wish I could just pick out my space and
hit
okay here we go
okay so now you're tagged
oh yeah Jim's like you're not drawing
your boat you're showing it like a best
dog like uh yeah Oh
okay what was that button I can just
like hit them cool get the hang of it
now guys okay
Kidman hold l1 then hold X
[Music]
that's a pig ever that I why not
hoggle whatever the hell is pump it's in
the Volta
well they've killed a ball harlot is not
same for in that
full of water no no no well that made me
sewer cuz that that's pretty cool
stout swam down
all the river
doubts when stuffs when
I got the eye
here they come
I'm very people I mean angry angry oh no
I'm a boy do you think
Kamel stuff
the ladies nice okay now what more stuff
over here
oh my god
nice bearing hang around hey Jose Nix
your Jogi Nix
hey Alex williamson's adventures and hey
- smiley face smiley face
oh thank you so much for coming as well
- smiley face mine that's all I can hope
you but yes your breasts I'm here
and hey Itachi
thank you for the compliment ah and
thank you yeah yeah Gomorrah me for
talking hey was she just feeling the
particles but that's my cue
so it means like I suppose relieves or
sorry I meant miring okay I want to open
the weapon real
[Music]
a fire arrow pack what
damn that's risk so how do I change my
arrows they all right do I change them
in here there's no like way to quick
change cannot assign them no Ajay huh
separate noise okay I'm so heading
towards my goal I still haven't gotten
that yet mmm oh I think I've gotten all
the stuff that I need though don't I
need to give some food to that woman I
know I'm talking to this caste guy
kill this game girl Jesus Christ
that's a lovely greeting
are you telling me to kill the game I
said that has a whole lot of me and kill
me kill me I'll kill everything within
the game oh stop moving I am using it
like a pistol Jesus I just can't help
when he was so fast oh yeah that was
another thing actually when I got given
my feedback for the game so far because
the Lizzie don't know I'm in university
studying games so I'm making my third
year game and he was like oh pretty good
but you're like a programmer and you're
a girl as well because I'll get you far
and I never know how to take those
compliments cuz I'm like you think but
at the same time I'm like I don't want
to have better chances just because of
my gender cuz then that makes me feel
like I have to like work hair that
nobody want to work harder but like I
want people to recognize me for my work
you know no not my my sex but anyway
that's just a thing this all vast animal
of talisman tail what is that like a new
necklace
actually get point what is that can I
know it's nothing to wear modifications
though was this
[Music]
Videl nothing can I write on it can I
write on it
hey Tom
okay so family I'm going over here isn't
that like a tribe town then I don't
think I don't think I should be doing
oh so I came from here so yeah I'm going
in here now
fair enough
see I gotta go
Oh
am I allowed in here I feel like I'm
gonna get into a fight hello
just because I'm shun doesn't mean I
won't pass through okay he said hiding
me there I was the outcast would go
bother someone else okay
wasn't that a one that I was supposed to
be seen to give her some food or
something
a campfire
little did I know a scrapper was doing
the same thing I will not be provoked by
an outcast I will not speak to those
cast out by the matrix fine rude
time to see cursed and get a trip caster
where is he though I hear that
oh yeah no good point Jim Hawk I will
keep an eye out to the herps and thanks
for let me know what the cream bar was
yeah the interim for this game was great
Tom it's pretty emotional but like I'm
so confused like why is she an outcast
what happens all those people I want to
find out all the things
keeping an eye out for her to get more
health
my god my way anymore
nope
where the bloody hell is it
but that way
does she not have like a stamina bar or
something she's just that fit that she
can run without the doses he'll be
waiting for me
[Music]
vacuum and so yummy there we go
who's nervous is he hiding why is he
doing
well well well an outcast on my doorstep
all mother protect me
surprised you saw me the way you keep
looking every other direction to make
sure no one's watching
careful there will spring your neck it's
always a pain in the neck when you show
up girl one way or another penny Tom
says I might cry at this key stop bags
my acting so clunky today once you run
the proving and get made a brave you'll
deal with traitors in mother's heart
maybe I don't like losing customers
traders who don't break the law and deal
with outcasts assuming that's right our
days of crime will be behind us so long
as you keep quiet are you worried I'm
going to tell someone that you traded
with outcasts I don't think you're the
kind who talks but you never know you
can stop worrying the secret's safe with
me
that's get some beads and put them in my
hair the only person I've ever told
about our trades is Rost yeah well not
like you can turn me in even if he
wanted to law and Duty sort of a man
that rust I don't know how you stand it
you really don't know why he was cast
out I've told you no I don't think
anyone knows what he did but it must
have been serious because his term is
for life hmm I want to know it rusted so
I'm guessing you know Tom and you know
Michael and you broke had a bit of a cry
at the end of the game why do you take
the risk
training with outcasts every time you
if a big meaningful talk is what you're
after move along
I love meaningful songs to be one isn't
it yeah got caught poking around one of
the metal ruins out beyond the embrace
matriarch said I was tainted and gave me
five years what did you see in the roads
nothing I can make sense of after my
shunning I tried living back in mother's
heart but everyone I knew had moved on
and there were so many people everywhere
I turned I liked it better out here
anyway last time I waited you had a trip
caster available for trade still got it
I do but you need to bring me a scrapper
lens what can I say special weapons
don't come cheap
oh I can pay took down a scrapper not
long ago stripped out the lens in
perfect condition I'll be the judge of
that
show me
and with one is a stripper lens do you
know on my talisman tail small
possessive scrapper islands cuz my
head's in the way small just a small
machine call the [ __ ] burn watcher lens
strider lens
I
it's gonna be one of these them right
yeah
[Music]
I'll just give you all my stuff
[Music]
have some fatty meat
ah
[Music]
can I have it now
[Music]
this weapon create straps which detonate
when the tripwire connecting two anchor
points is broken it's best used across
enemy patrol paths or in narrow spaces
cool
what's happening here
why are you selling materials I don't
know he said he wanted to scrap a thing
and I couldn't find it so I was giving
him everything this like a guess
[Music]
do I need anything I don't probably
can't afford anything else cool Bose
where does it say how much I've gone oh
I do have certain
whatever
pain movie
that's cool
[Music]
now that you've got yourself a trip
caster practice how to use it someplace
else all right
my life's exciting enough without a
bunch of shock wire booby traps to trip
over really could have fooled me I like
her attitude will you be around later in
case I want to make another trade I'll
be here
same as usual bring me the parts you
harvest from any machines you hunt the
better the parts the more shards I'll
pay and be sure to take a close look at
my inventory though who knows maybe I've
got something that could give you an
edge in the proving hey spaz Yin
I love how everyone says hi to everyone
it's so nice hmm I guess that concludes
our business all right good luck in the
proving blessing of all mother and all
that Thanks how's that what I need time
to meet Rost at the north gate
don't you need to meet that woman you
know go and give her some meat or
something no
[Applause]
well scared of me
again nuts give this a guy
I want this wet lawyer didn't hit too
far
yeah something like that are you gonna
come over here
bolos
but he's giving it come here
balls it's too low down I mean high I
mean you're sneaky
oh my god
right this one was freaking ridiculous
why is that so high
well I try to eat it I put it too high
the other one work though and the other
one works pretty good I'm just gonna
keep that in mind
put them low down unless I'm working
with those big ones giving directions to
a streamer go left keep it up good
smooth air always always
it's my one name for smooth gameplay
yeah course it is
I need to get some medicine medical
herbs I probably will say no just get
some more hours
[Music]
[Applause]
secrets
ah quite a few then
I'm really enjoying this this is fun
I've been wanting to play another open
wild game where I can just kind of get
lost in it
just go around explore a bit kill some
stuff loot some stuff it's small some
staff finds and caves talk to some weird
people and then enjoy some nice scenery
is that chicken such a game I swear I
his head a chicken I find to seize his
chickens cuz the last game I got fully
immersed in was fallout 3 I'm gonna go
it was
oh there's so many stop Mei heck
don't worry I know I'm going the wrong
way but I'm just leaving because I'm
trying to get some help and I swear I
keep on hearing chickens where are these
chickens what's this oh sorry alight
chickens
well it's going
[Music]
where's this there it is Turkey no save
this earlier Thank You Turkey but you're
a sacrifice I will eat tonight sometimes
I wish I could just experience like
going back to these times and just
living in the forest and stuff and just
like doing nothing but running around
and jumping on rocks oh my god thank you
for 150 SEC I don't know what that is in
my monies but thank you so much um ah
and you're like I know we had to say was
thank you for the wonderful streaming
good night Oh
have a lovely evening Jonathan I'm
guessing you're going to bed or
something so thanks for coming I
appreciate it and do a little some
coming parents never know what to do
oh and I have like something I do to say
thank you to everyone whenever they do
that but yeah we'll come up with
something where's the campfire cuz I
want to save
never know when I might need these
here we go getting loose good stuff
what what what where are they
yeah
turkey in Turkey turkey where are the
bloody hell are these people
[Applause]
you're an idiot wait maybe not discuss
on my hair isn't nice just blend in
yeah bugger off all right so where are
these people
[Music]
did I miss them no I think I think I am
a comment because over here where then
green might need that yeah it's gonna be
here right
[Music]
no we haven't use a fire one yet
just insane that over and over over what
the bloody hell are you are you up there
yeah Wow Wow oh my God look at that that
looks like a massive mechanical octopus
now that is impressive
but let's let's keep learning Chinese er
hi who are you calling out for do you
need help I have nothing against
outcasts for 4-minute
but I shouldn't talk to you I don't want
to get in trouble I don't see anyone
else around to help I guess you're right
and no one else want to see sorry I
didn't mean to be careless
my brother was cast out what his
sentence has ended he he should have
come home but he didn't and and his camp
was covered in blood covered in blood
um you said your brother's camp was
soaked with blood
the Braves went looking for Evan and
that's what they found all I can think
about is what might have happened is he
really dead
or maybe just wounded is he suffering
does he need help I can't stand it not
knowing what are you doing out here all
alone each day I cut a notch on the wall
so I knew Brom sentence was over then I
cut three more but he still hadn't come
back I begged the matriarch to send
Braves to find him and all they found
was a blood-soaked camp the Braves that
he must be dead but I have to know the
truth
so I came out looking for him why was
your brother cast out rom was always a
little different a little touched one of
the hunters had a cruel heart and never
let him alone
what does that mean - sighs him like
always but this time Brom struck back
with a rock and split the man's skull
spirits made him do it
he said whispers of the Forgotten it
cost him ten years never should have
left him alone
what do you mean forgotten all mother
curses blasphemers who won't repent
banishing them from her eternal memory
those lost spirits are the Forgotten rom
used to say they spoke to him told him
to do things it was such a burden for
him and and there was nothing I could do
to help I'll do what I can to find your
brother you will she's so nice let me
come with you I won't be a bother I know
how to stay out of sight
I'm faster on my own if that is how it
must be just find him then please
maybe these okay
[Music]
Wow this is something different
[Music]
what the hell is that thing
Oh time for me traps Oh bull okay pretty
one yeah I won their site but ago that
guy that guy I go that guy over my traps
wait so what would have saved but would
have mean talking to her and activating
that side quest I'll be there yeah sweet
I didn't [ __ ] bother to find her
brother right I said why would her
brother even baby
ah that's forgot I'm sure I'll end up
going back there right
let's see well I adds an age like what
should i do guy should just carry on
girl should I go back to the Forgotten
oh yeah that's not grass a person
I'm gonna do that actually enough
so I'm not saying that much I'm just
like privy today and I'm a little bit
tired so I've been working on my
dissertation and then oh my god I wish I
could tell you the dudes like cat well I
might be able to see I don't know I'm
just figuring out whether it's a yea or
nay
like for sure but basically there's
something that I didn't fight it - oh
right but for it to happen I am finished
- stated earlier
oh my god
Jesus these things really difficult that
mission is just animal hunting which one
the one at the camp hasn't even played
to the moon yeah I played to the moon
dar was sad I didn't play it on the
channel though because that was before
that was before YouTube times that was
down those a long time ago
yeah played some minisodes on YouTube
the thing is like when I play things
with that and then people are like why
don't you play again with the channel
I'm just like no because games like that
a very narrative driven and once you've
played it once I did I'll just find the
high speed games again and actually be
enjoying myself just like the whole
works
what PewDiePie said I'm not gonna play a
game that I don't actually want to play
because I am NOT faking my reactions and
I will be bored so yeah basically okay I
don't want to go that but I do want to
go here
I'm gonna get around
[Applause]
no no get a nut please do your part core
stuff wait can I not like yay I'm just
jumping everywhere but I remember when I
used to play Skyrim and you just spend
like hours trying to climb to the top of
the highest mountain I could see this
what is it a watch your name
so I even have some meat for her hello
Branagh she won't talk to you since I
was cast out have I not been constant oh
so she's no pop as I not get the vow and
provide for me once more good news
grotto once again all mother has brought
you rabbits I didn't kill any rabbits
you're looking half the raccoon that
distant Thunder I hear the sounds of
grief Oh mother I would join the call
but I left my prayer beads at time
Mustafa I am and I sign wait video camp
for me grotto Oh see what I can do
wait sorry what she want
[Music]
go to overlook climb
[Music]
dang soaked the melted snow seasons have
weird in this game I guess it's supposed
to be like in the future so climate
change be that's beautiful though love
don't fall I wish you could advise the
mechanical horsey things really want to
know come here yeah
hey freeze coil that's not fatal what is
that here no one else will help me oh I
gotta do everything around here but no
one even likes me injured I need your
help
okay one sec please a word
you want to talk to an outcast I'm
desperate for help whatever the
consequences what's the problem then
trouble with your leg forget about me
it's my daughter or Rana she's in danger
she went after a scrapper to your
mother's cradle them I fear for her life
I can't even stand up let alone go after
her will you help me find her uh you
know the matrix might cast you out for
speaking to me don't you
I don't care I tried looking for him
myself and my leg gave out just find her
I'll accept any punishment if it means
she's safe that's good dad that's sweet
why would your daughter hunt a scrapper
on her own it's my fault I went after it
first and it tore up my leg I barely got
away
I left a spear and held in the machine
that spear was made by Adina my mate
who died last year
it means everything to aronia she she
went after the scrapper to get it back
you said Arana went to mother's cradle
yes southeast of here I forbid her from
going that ever since her mother died
she's become impossible
dammit look at me a way to learn how a
crippled father that can't find his
daughter
please help me set things right
oh yeah I can to help your daughter make
sure shut light light three sidequest
going down
stuff up
[Music]
wait so am i heading to
overlook climb okay so that was for that
woman but they also need to go here
they've forgotten camp and in her
mother's footsteps and there let's go
here I'm intrigued
where's my little waypoint where I put
it and put it there here
[Music]
I must be wrong guys why are you some
trouble
oh sure that's my father while you're
here
if anyone has like good knowledge on oh
wait I learned in my skills don't swim
sure sure please computers and stuff I'm
looking to upgrade my laptop and won't
get shut up you're waving in my ear and
we'll get a desktop I know I'm not gonna
be like basically and we're gonna have a
house for a while so we live it up from
my back I will have houses don't worry
but I mean like not stable one so can't
be picking up her desktop computer and
moving every few months
Oh
so yeah basically anyone video editing
and after-effects rendering so I'm just
see how they can focus I can hardly hear
myself okay and it'd be cool if I could
like play little games online and stuff
but that's not the main thing machine I
was looking at gaming laptops and
there's some pretty good ones but then
I'm like because it's pic gaming like
what a burning be great for video when I
tell you got a minute yeah yeah yeah
yeah thank you
I thought those Watchers were gonna tear
me apart your father sent me after him
it's time to go home
I figured but I can't go back until I
get my mother's beer from that scrapper
oh yeah Speer must mean a lot too
yes hi mom it's not long before she died
I can't believe my father lost it he
didn't mean to
scrappers well they like I know I just
can't stand the idea that it might be
gone forever like a tree on a half-full
head your father is worried sick about
you he gets worried if I go ten steps to
relieve myself in the bushes he just he
doesn't want to lose you oh boy
I know but I do wish he wouldn't yell at
me so much how did you wind up in that
tree I tracked the scrapper to mothers
cradle caught a glimpse of it too but
then a watcher saw me and called his
pack my own mother and just not a good
enough hunter to get that spear back am
I
I should probably won't care about to
that Dad but I know I bought from your
spirit you will oh thank you go find
your father
his leg gave out while he was searching
for you just south of matters much Oh No
okay I'll go to him right away thanks
again yes so you put your dad in danger
save
[Music]
yeah
this is quite nice thing
[Music]
so let's do that well the bloody hell
mother's cradle break for this watch
ruins why okay
here
am i just like following randomly
we're the gun
[Music]
oh there's mother's cradle what's this
[Music]
it's the merchants neck
Geron are the bottom words follower
bonus tracks fun scrapper
alright
oh that's cool
nice go look out the suburbs
I thought the ruins might be where you
fell thanks for clarifying that Michael
another one that
okay
these trailers here must be why she's on
a scrappy
I might doing this scrappers are bad you
reckon probably
[Music]
so yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you can tell when I get tired when I'm
streaming because like yeah I get chewy
here where did it go yeah it's a turkey
no it's not so much it's a fawn I don't
want to hurt anyone folks this
could you guys in real life kill an
animal and ease it out in real life I
think if I were to eat me again it would
only be if I'd killed it but I don't
think I've your feelings
all right such a team game I just love
it just everything about this game just
screams awesome I mean mainly because of
our hair but you know where's the track
yeah
which way throws the trap
the trail ends here I'll bet it cross
the river better check the other side
okay
[Music]
people-people playfully books is what
there i go i wish i gonna kill my dad
Oh Jim so high I got my second
gymnastics lesson tomorrow I'm kind of
scared because my body aches for days
after the first one was this a decade
but ya know I'm excited I will be doing
backflips one day guys one day now I've
just gotta like actually be able to hold
a handstand for longer than si he's a
little outcast camps hey what am i doing
where am I going
oh yeah gotta follow the tracks keep
getting sidetracked old I'm actually
doing this again
where did it go it went this way and
then why
lalalala
[Music]
Jesus this thing moved so far away
scaring all the balls
hi I've found them again where am i what
I'm all the way here okay
hello Mike thank you for coming
please excuse well their time to get
that spear
okay so many followers today hi hello
but I wasn't quite an easy on
PlayStation ah the toy just used to get
like all these from the press and now
I'm just I used to accept amounts it's
got too many Oh
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
yep let's retry that one that wasn't the
best attempt was it no oh I have no idea
what level I'm at but that's good point
maybe we should go to my skill
[Music]
I'm a level-4
[Music]
that's probably good
that's good
oh that one's good Susa a lot
oh I like this one
oh I can't learn it damn it Oh any time
just to get these right okay sir press I
want for my side at a time
oh this could be a good son takedown
that's that's actually pretty good time
stirs what aiming to triples our landing
from a fall or jumps to meet silent
that's pretty you do well aiming total
to slow down time that's pretty good
press oh one for a high damage attack on
down
and light spirits will have an increased
chance to mobile armor
[Music]
can have this one
grab this one cannot this one so damn
time
hang out this one so weird happy though
okay thanks for that Michael
small Sheen's and humans and humans well
I guess there's probably some point in
the game where these tribesmen hate
outcasts so much that they try and kill
me
sweet fad I'd I'd rather kill humans
yeah okay no I don't agree okay so
that's be a lot more stealthy than I was
[Applause]
I'll say
hey I got another [ __ ] yeah
well
this thing
got the one
you can see me crap get up get up get up
get up
my hair is hitting my neck
[ __ ]
they're scanning for me take down
takedown how do I focus on a date down
plus r1 okay Bowles I did not do that
right did I yep dad definitely was not
silent takedown
she's purely gone away there were little
I should put my cap you said I should
put up like some trap wire for when they
get out they're probably good place to
fight from though if I do like so my
traps right I was using I to at the end
there anyway anyway I'm tired so I'm
gonna leave this for another dig think I
was worked by I can't say right yeah
Sammis accounts like that yeah cuz I
guys do another five hundreds and my
dissertation tomorrow yeah and then I've
got my gymnastics which should be fun
because I get to just jump around and
have myself whoa new year's resolutions
but yeah do you come back next week
where are we playing more of this did
you guys enjoy it I think you other you
enjoyed it Oh wrong button I think you
enjoy it right you seem to enjoy it so
that's the main thing
[Music]
but yeah I'll play you a little song
it's I'm so worried that I don't play it
well but I guess this is the whole point
of playing it to you guys because then I
get to have your feedback
let me turn down the music thing cuz oh
wait unless I just yeah there you go
I wanted to do like another cover for
the channel because I've been doing a
lot of originals and they still have
some originals to do but I wanted to
sing like a cover of a song and I was
listening to linkin park the other day
and one more light came on and I was
like oh this would be so sweet to sing
but it's the only thing is it's really
high-pitched so I've had I've had to
change it on boring just play whoa
someone's a little bit rude thinking
that they're entitled but yeah so I was
like this would sound so good on the
ukulele I'm just getting up
the chords and then yeah lucky for me
there was a little tutorial online but
yeah I'm just gonna sing it to you guys
and we'll see how it sounds thanks for
sticking up for me guys you can't wait
what I didn't trade in my boat oh okay
I was like excuse me you know I have my
bow in the game low yeah ideally it
would be cool to be get it I you know my
problem is I want to do everything like
the whole reason I'm doing gymnastics is
because I just want to like be able to
do flips and just run around like she
does like they do in the games I want to
be like that and in a real person cuz
it's so sad that we never do that I
don't know well I think it is anyway
like I would have run around and jump
off cliffs and like scale things and I
don't know it just seems like a really
fun way to be um but anyway okay I'm
nervous
cuz it's I know it's a song that means a
lot to a lot of people sorry I don't
know batter it butter and bruise it but
that's let's just see I'm gonna take off
my headphones
[Music]
should've stay whether I ignore can I
help you not to anymore there are things
we care half I can't keep if they say
who cares if wampa like your who's out
in the sky of million stars it's like a
stickers
who cares with something's time runs out
if a moment is all we are be quicker
quicker
who cares if one blue light goes out
[Music]
there with my tongue
[Music]
from your feet in the kitchen on March
then need Oh and angry and you should be
it's not fair just cause they can't see
it doesn't mean it isn't there if they
say who cares if want one like the rules
out in the sky of milk and starts
flickers flickers who cares the
someone's time runs out if a moment is
all we are quicker quicker
who cares if one blue light goes out
to
[Music]
who cares for more like goes out in a
sky of embell in stars who cares
someone's time runs out if a moment it's
all we are who cares
like
[Music]
something like that and so I want to
show on the ending and like obviously I
had to sing it a bit differently but I
don't know what do you think so I like
keep working on it and record it for the
channel oh it seemed like you guys liked
it I getting claps and the fights like
talking I think I know where that comes
from
ah Mike Robinson I'm sorry but if it
made you feel things that's dead
literally the first time I started this
so lame oh thank you so much Michael
doing you know dance to say thank you
and thank you fling horizon you love me
love me that's is sweet and thank you
all for joining yes thank you all for
joining
but yeah I'm so I'm so glad you guys
like that song because that song means a
lot to me and I know it means a lot to a
lot of people especially after what
happened last year and then there were a
lot of people grew up with that band and
help them through stuff so I want to do
it justice if I do put out on the
channel so I'm gonna practice it more
practice it more perhaps a bit more
record it properly yeah I think you'll
be nice cuz I think it fits my voice I
know it's quite high-pitched but yeah I
think once I play it properly it should
be good good ah I'm glad yeah without
each other with you anyway thank you so
much for coming have a lovely day or
evening
jolly good show chats I just saying that
cuz done will said that in the chat by
the way and yeah I'll see you next
Wednesday but you can see me next Monday
which is when the next video will be up
so make sure to follow me on Twitter
Instagram for life updates also snapchat
I do have a tendency to go on crazy
snapchat like sometimes I'll just snap
Jam there'll be so many snaps point the
snaps for my day and then I won't use it
for a few days it's weird but anyway
yeah and Twitter
obviously Twitter I like to tweet I
tweet a lot about weird things it's just
in my head
pick them out great love Twitter anyway
have a lovely day or evening I will say
goodbye to the ones I can see in the
chat sorry if I can't say goodbye to all
of you but I will do it now so goodbye
Michael and thank you again goodbye
silver shadow Mike Robinson bye Homer
goodbye Cedric goodbye yakima fink by
mrs. teen later good bye Daniel
goodbye Jim Hoge by nathan ballantine
goodbye someone friendly oh that's sweet
that's sweet goodbye oh no I'm sorry
Nathan Nathan just got here hello and
goodbye
I'll keep this up I'll keep this up but
you probably wanted to be here for the
live show didn't you but here you go you
got nervous so I'm talking to you no
that's a big deal oh no now I'm suddenly
going to be candid I just mean like you
know like you cut everyone Nathan Nathan
everyone there you go that's your man
I'm gonna shut up now
I'm just digging um goodbye did I say
Mike Robinson did I say Jim Hawk well
goodbye
anyway and yeah that's everyone i can
see i'm scrolling up but yeah that's
everyone I think so if I missed you but
goodbye everyone in the in the chat
we're obviously in the chat but goodbye
everyone watching as well all of you
lurkers who are watching but you're not
typing or you're watching on a console
or you're watching somewhere look on a
TV that you can't get involved with the
chat
goodbye American American Jim's like
you're on like I have a tendency to do
that but yeah goodbye
have love dear evening goodbye I'm gonna
go down so what would always be my BAE
BAE BAE BAE BAE BAE BAE BAE back hey